Token optimist turned mincemeat courtesy
of a particularly bloodthirsty "vampire
bat," Glenn was a "Walking Dead" favorite.
So, come time for him to bite the dust,
why was actor Steven Yeun so down to
say adios to his adored character?
"Hey you. Dumbass."
Sweating, scared, and hopeless, Rick
Grimes is stuck in a tank surrounded
by walkers on all sides in the series
premiere of "The Walking Dead". He's
not stupid. He knows he's finished,
until a voice comes in over the radio.
"Yeah, you in the tank. Cozy in there?"
Before we learn who's behind the voice,
the camera zooms out over the city of
Atlanta and the episode ends. Episode
2, however, wastes no time introducing
this mysterious new character to us:
Glenn Rhee, played by Steven Yeun.
Glenn became a fan favorite over the course
of the show, reminding viewers that there's
light even in the darkest of times. "The Walking
Dead" itself, however, doesn't play favorites,
and Glenn meets his fate in the form of Negan's
bat Lucille at the beginning of Season 7. Yeun
had no choice but to leave after that, seeing as
Glenn's demise was more than definitive. However,
there's more to his departure than
just his character's untimely death.
Steven Yeun spoke with fellow thespian
Riz Ahmed for Variety's Actors on Actors,
and naturally, "The Walking Dead" came up.
Being part of a series that big doesn't just
vanish from the public consciousness when
an actor moves on to different projects,
after all — especially when they play a character
as beloved as Glenn. It's an extremely special
role to Yeun, but he also openly admitted that
he didn't mind leaving the character behind.
Glenn is a "plucky, nice guy — nice to everybody,"
Yeun said, and, while he enjoys expressing that
part of himself as an actor, he was only able to
do it for so long before it got to him. Yeun said:
From his perspective, that limited
where he was able to go as an actor,
and being or feeling boxed in is the last
thing any actor wants; it was time to move on.
When the writers decided to
kill Glenn off, Yeun says:
"There really wasn't much of a fight on my end."
He added, however, that "it
was still sad" regardless.
Since departing from post-apocalyptic
Georgia, Yeun has made the most of his time,
appearing in critically acclaimed projects
like "Sorry to Bother You," "Burning," and
"Minari" — productions that allowed him
to explore roles other than the "genial
natured guy." Fans will always
remember and miss Yeun as Glenn,
but it's a wonderful thing that he's been
able to expand his body of work elsewhere.
In the years since his "Walking Dead" goodbye,
Steven Yeun has taken up some remarkable acting
opportunities. He's expanded his filmography
while trying out roles that, not too long ago,
he likely wouldn't have had a chance at landing.
Nevertheless, in the eyes of many, he'll always
be the man behind Glenn Rhee. With that in
mind, as "The Walking Dead" franchise expands
in all directions, could we see Yeun return
to the role of Glenn in some form or fashion?
During a July 2022 appearance on the "Conan
O'Brien Needs a Friend" podcast, Yeun made
it abundantly clear that the end of his "Walking
Dead" tenure was indeed the end. He told O'Brien:
This confirmed without a shadow of a
doubt that he's done with the Glenn
role from here on out. Continuing, Yeun added:
Even though it would be cool to see Glenn Rhee
in the "Walking Dead" universe one more time,
don't get your hopes up that it'll happen. If his
comments and career trajectory prove anything,
it's that Steven Yeun has left "TWD"
and his iconic character in the past.